foreign
from the headquarters of Ramsey
Solutions broadcasting from the PODS
moving and storage Studio it's the
Ramsay show where America hangs out to
have a conversation about your life and
your money I'm Ramsay personality George
Campbell joined by my pal and Confidant
best-selling author Ken Coleman was here
as well and he is excited to take your
calls about work about purpose about
your career and boy is there a lot in
the news in that regard Ken so we're
going to get to that yeah taking your
money questions Georgie boy is uh the
expert I mean he just flat out knows how
to answer it I was bragging about you
over the break I was talking to some
friends I said I got to connect you to
my uh my pal they were asking me a
little bit of a nuanced uh money
question that was your way to get out of
it I'm Your Baby Steps guy I'm your FPU
uh coordinator a guy the nuanced
retirement
question some of that you're the guy
yeah and you've done a great job so
George is here for the money questions
I'm the work guy at Ramsey Solutions so
you know uh your work your job is your
greatest wealth building tool as David
said for decades I want to help you
there I want to help you maximize your
potential there so if you got a sticky
situation an unknown should I take the
leap in 2023 I'm here to answer those
questions so let's have some fun today
the number to call is triple eight eight
two five five two two five that's triple
eight eight two five five two two five
and happy New Year uh to all of you
listening out there America it's our
first show back in 2023. I broke out the
cardigan it was time yeah I felt like
the cardigan was the uh first of the
year of The Cardigans yeah I love it
well let's jump into it uh Adam is
kicking us off this hour in New York
City Adam welcome to the show
hello George hello Ken good afternoon
thank you very much for taking the call
and happy New Year happy New Year thank
you what's going on
uh just speaking of nuance right someone
of a nuanced question that I also think
would present kind of a deeper dive into
finances and other items but one thing
that and just to give background to the
question right I'm a younger person 30
years old have a decent amount of
savings set up and I've been with my
partner my girlfriend for about almost
three years now when you break down in
just in terms of percentages and savings
you know the Big Goal that I have for
myself is buying a home somewhat have
left that Arena over the last 18 months
or so due to the crazy things you've
seen in the tri-state area more
specifically New Jersey but I have about
if you could pool our assets right maybe
about 90 to 95 percent of what to go
into and you know she's a child of
divorce people in my family are no
stranger to divorce and one thing I'm
thinking about doing is trying to
acquire a house as a pre-marital asset
in a way of kind of protecting myself
not knowing what the future would hold I
don't know if that's the right way to be
thinking about it but working in finance
maybe I'm Jaded by seeing this over time
and time again so maybe that's not the
best mindset to have but I can't help it
I think that could be a benefit to me in
a Smart Financial move so how is that I
get your opinion on that before we weigh
in on the opinion and and George leading
on this one I I'm just curious
why do you think that's a good move and
it's funny that you refer to it as a
pre-marital asset it's very very stuffy
very very uh you know like most romantic
Ken no not at all what is it what do you
think it's going to do for you
well so I've seen before where if in the
event that me and my girlfriend take the
next step and it doesn't work out within
whether that's
six months two years five years ten
years over timeline that may be hold on
a second hold on hold on hold on hold on
and I'm just trying to get context
if you take the next step does that mean
get married
correct and it doesn't work out so we're
already we're already uh planning for
the worst
uh it's something that I've done for
most of my life that I have a hard time
not doing
yeah isn't having the worst in your mind
and trying to plan so keep going so if
the worst happens why is having this
premarital asset known as a house why is
that protecting you
my understanding is that if
right worst case scenario would be we
get divorced
um I lose the house and now I kind of
have to restart over and my
understanding is it was a pre-marital
asset and then we decided to sell the
home we would have equal access to the
proceeds where I wouldn't essentially be
kicked out of my own house or something
like that all right George that's what I
needed to know got it now we see where
he's coming from
well you're what you're saying is and
correct me if I'm wrong you want to buy
this house your name is on the the deed
your name is on the mortgage and her
name is not a part of this at all let's
say you guys get married you would still
it would remain that way
correct
you're asking for a roommate at that
point why would she not want some skin
in the game too and say hey what's
what's mine is now ours this is we
that's a good thing so when you look at
the dating go well this is my thing I
had before we were married and so I'm
going to keep it in my name to play it
safe what do you think that does to her
emotionally and mentally
yeah it's a very fair point and I hold
no ill will towards her whatsoever and
would obviously want to welcome you
didn't answer the question in my life
you did not answer the question you're a
very thoughtful young man I mean like
really thoughtful but if you're on the
answer put yourself in her shoes how do
you think she's gonna feel
terrible
all right that's just not how I want to
start the marriage now I understand the
heart of it you're scared because you've
seen this play out in your family and
you've seen people with I you've seen
the YouTube comments on any video about
marriage where they're saying don't get
married it's she's just trying to take
you for all your words you're going to
take you to the cleaners they all sound
like that to me if for some reason in
the comment section
and it's just a real kind of gross
Outlook towards marriage there's a lot
of negativity a lot of cynicism and I
think the best thing you can do if you
really want to go this route you can do
a prenup if there's inordinate levels of
wealth let's say you're coming in you've
got a million dollar debt worth and
she's not working or she makes a smaller
salary you could pursue a prenup as a
way to protect yourselves
but doing the kind of shady I did this
before we were married so it's mine
that's going to create a ruffle and so I
would talk about it first of all
communicate as a couple and decide
together what we're going to do if
you're even going to go that route
okay I see what you mean because I never
knew that those things I thought that
even a prenup
I don't know I guess I'm not really good
at preparing for the worst I just didn't
even know that here's the deal I I I I
think it's one thing to batten down the
hatches if you will an old phrase that
when a storm is coming let's let's kind
of protect the windows
but you don't know that there's a storm
coming
that's a good point it's it's like you
know because you try and time everything
perfect and you worst case scenario
isn't the way you should live your
entire life Adam Adam how old are you
30. Adam I am 48 and next May or this
coming May Stacey and I will celebrate
25 years of marriage
now I'm not a marriage expert
congratulations thank you I don't say
that to get Applause I appreciate the
lobby folks saying that but I tell you
this here's what I've learned in 25
years of marriage
you can't plan for much at all other
than your emergency fund right because
life is going to happen it's gonna rain
that's why we preach the emergency fund
I would tell you this if you can afford
the house the way that we teach it to do
it and you get the house and then bring
her in once you get married and it's our
house and then if the worst happens you
still made a good financial decision and
you're still better off George I'm I'm
with you on that and when that time
comes there's a lot of state laws
there's a lot of things that you need to
take into account if it did go south and
so you can do some research do your
homework but don't let that delay you
from getting married and making it weak
that's what marriage is if you don't
want that don't sign up for marriage
it's going to end in a pain for both
parties here so thank you so much for
the call wishing you the best man the
number to call Triple eight eight two
five five two two five this is the
Ramsay show
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
welcome back to the Ramsay show I'm
George camel joined by Ken Coleman this
hour and it's a free call at triple
eight eight two five five two two five
and if you like this show which I hope
you are you're listening to it right now
would you mind doing us a huge favor and
leaving a review sharing with a friend
subscribing wherever you're listening
following that helps us spread the
impact of this show we want to reach as
many people as we can this year and give
them hope in every area whether it's
their money their career their health
and so we really appreciate that triple
eight eight two five five two two five
is a number to call Lauren's up next in
Oklahoma City Lauren welcome to the
Ramsay show
hey guys Happy New Year thanks so much
for taking my call Happy New Year how
can we help
um so I am trying to figure out you know
how do you guys uh calculate or estimate
how long it will take take someone to
pay off debt or me in particular to pay
home for any I love it well that's a
great goal to have how much debt do you
have
um between credit cards student loans
and my car it's uh right around 69 000.
okay and what's your income
okay and uh how much margin do you have
right now have you started doing a
budget have you been uh kind of
following our steps for a little while
or is this all new to you
yeah um I actually started
um my budgeting uh about I think like
October so a couple couple months ago
and um I've got roughly I've got well no
I have set 500 extra that I can for sure
put towards it
um but you know sometimes I have a
little bit more than that that I can do
like to just um that's all I know I can
do that's great well it takes about 90
days to get that budget really dialed in
and so you're right about that point
you've got some margin left over and we
have a great tool actually on our
website the debt snowball calculator
where you can input every single one of
your numbers and it will show you based
on how much extra you're throwing at
that very first debt exactly how long it
will take uh have you been through
Financial Peace University before
uh no sir I haven't okay well I'm gonna
gift that to you hey to Kickstart the
new year and uh there's a bunch of tools
and resources inside of that as well as
of course the nine video lessons and so
much more so if you hang on the line
I'll get that to you and we're still
going to talk about your situation but I
want to let you know that is kind of the
next steps for you so the 69 how much oh
absolutely so the 69 in debt you're
making 66 what are you doing for work
um I'm a civilian federal
okay awesome and can are you able to
work overtime
um
some but no no not like
do you have personal uh Freedom that
means in your personal life to take on a
second job
give me something I could kind of make
my own schedule
um just you know with kids and wife and
whatever so how many hours would you
have just a rough estimate I know you
got to sit down and figure this out but
what would you say you'd have in a given
week to put towards uh a second job side
Hustle
um
maybe
10 to 15 hours right uh what we want you
to do is is uh and again George gave you
that great resource uh the calculator
the debt payoff that that thing is
phenomenal it's going to give you the
the answer you called in for but we want
to speed that up and if you can put 10
to 15 hours a week in at let's say 15 an
hour just run that exercise for yourself
just to see what could be and then you
begin to look okay where can I go get
something for 10 to 15 hours that pays
me 15 an hour or more I don't want you
to limit yourself to 15 an hour it's
just an example and Lauren when it comes
to debt payoff obviously we want a big
chunk as possible to throw at that first
debt that's the debt snowball list them
all out smallest to largest attack the
first one with a Vengeance and as you're
doing that it becomes kind of addictive
to see how much more can I throw at this
next month and next month and so when it
comes to margin you said you have 500
bucks extra I want to figure out ways to
get more margin so that's what we're
doing right now there's only two ways to
get it you can spend less or you can
make more and making more on top of
working extra you could sell stuff
what's this car worth
um I I don't know for certain but
um maybe 25 26
000 ish and what do you owe on it
um 16. okay so there's an option I'm not
saying go do that tomorrow but it's an
option to go hey I could sell this car
for 26. I owe 16 that leaves me with ten
thousand dollars I can go buy a five
thousand six thousand eight thousand
dollar car free me up from that payment
and have a few grand left over to throw
out the debt
and so if this looks like it's too long
of a journey that is something I would
consider doing what is your car payment
every month
um I
um 295. boom so that makes it instead of
500 margin you get 800 now now you're
starting to cook with gas and you get
another side hustle 200 bucks 300 bucks
now you're over a thousand a month to
throw out the debt and so my goal for
you would be to have this paid off based
on the numbers I'm seeing within two
years
does that feel like a stretch for you
right now
um I mean yes
that's that's kind of why I'm I'm just
whenever I kind of tried to calculate it
it was looking at you know maybe like
four or five years when you see that 500
number well if you do that for the year
that's only six grand you threw at that
pile of debt right and so we need to
find a way to make that more like 20
grand a year 30 grand a year being
thrown at this debt and if you could get
to you know 33 a year that's with the
payments you're already making that
would get you there in two years and
that's the average amount of time it
takes for folks following our baby steps
with gazelle intensities 18 to 24 months
they pay off all Consumer Debt and I
believe it's possible for you
okay yeah that's what I was trying to
work out is how can I how can I be one
of those people with the average
difference to sell stuff I can tell you
we've covered cutting expenses getting
on that budget we've covered making more
money but selling stuff I'll give you a
real life example okay we have an
emergency fund but I hate touching it
the only thing I hate more than touching
my emergency fund is taxes all right I
don't know how much I don't like pulling
money out of the emergency fund all
right so we recently had a situation
where one of our kids wanted to change
schools we were in a contract we did not
realize the contract was tough to get
out of
so we had a three thousand dollar kind
of a penalty
and I could have it's not an emergency
right I could but we needed to come up
with it quickly and I hadn't budgeted
for it you know we did George what'd you
do you sold something we sold several
things and came up with almost all of it
wow yeah give me what was the highest
ticket item you sold oh geez give me
something you're gonna make me say this
you know what it is it's not a car no I
sold the Peloton whoa I got over it wow
and I know how much you love that
Peloton I loved it but it had its season
for you oh I got and I knew it was a
depreciating asset and I got I got over
a thousand bucks for that that's pretty
good let me tell you something I just
want people to understand now that we
didn't have to do that I could have
changed my budget
and paid for the three thousand dollars
but I mean why am I laying around the
house well we found it I mean we found
we had a lot of things we sold several
things we sold some clothes we sold some
stuff around the house on ENT stuff that
we just weren't like we looked there
first yeah and almost created the entire
amount from selling that's impressive so
Lauren start searching the couch
cushions and uh closets see what you can
sell on Facebook Marketplace and make
some extra money on the side and if you
do all of those things compounded so if
you go through your budget you say what
am I actually paying for every month you
know I don't need that subscription
right now I can cut that I'm overpaying
for insurance because it's my old buddy
from State Farm when I was in I'm gonna
start searching for Alexander Insurance
to see if I can get a better rate you
start to do that across every single
area and all of a sudden you go oh my
gosh I just gave myself a raise I found
500 bucks a month to throw this dead
well is your old buddy is your old buddy
from State Farm Jake by the way there's
always a guy named Jake okay and it's
always a guy you went to college with
who sold you on some insurance plan and
that you forgot to look at Lauren you
got this don't you
yes you got some you got some confidence
now don't you
yeah I actually just went through all my
subscriptions the other night and either
less than them or cancel them all
together and I shuffled some things
around to where it's a little more a
little easier to see
um you know
and Lauren you've got you've got friends
right
she has friends she's got lots of don't
borrow their Netflix password if you
want to watch something that'll be all
right hey I hear Netflix is cracking
down on that George before they do it's
time to catch up on Emily in Paris right
Ken there I don't even know what that is
he's pretending he's a huge fan all
right Lauren hang on the line Austin's
gonna pick up we're gonna gift you one
year Financial Peace University as well
as every dollar premium to help you
along this journey and here's my only
request if I give you all that I want
you to come and do your debt free scream
and share your story with America to
show them what the other side of gazelle
intensity looks like we are so proud of
you this is the Ramsay show
[Applause]
foreign
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
foreign welcome back to the Ramsay show
I'm George Campbell joined by Ken
Coleman this hour and on the debt free
stage in the lobby of Ramsey Solutions
it's Amanda hey Amanda how you doing hey
so if you're on the debt free stage it
means one thing only you are debt free
yes congratulations thank you where are
you from
um well I was living in Georgia when I
was paying off debt but I'm currently in
the process of moving to Colorado and
all my stuff is in a storage pod look at
you did you use pods
that wasn't even planned wow George with
a little extra Commission on that that's
a big win for me okay so Amanda uh tell
us how much debt you paid off a little
over 60 000 in 19 months whoa that's
pretty intense what was your range of
income during that time I started at 74
000 and then with working overtime
weekends at a second job I went up to
about a hundred thousand wow you're not
scared of work that's for sure what do
you do yeah what do you do I'm an
occupational therapist wow great career
and then what was the overtime second
job as an occupational therapist at the
local hospital to work weekends stick to
what you know and it makes good money
yeah that's fantastic so what kind of
debt was the 60. um it was about 40 000
of student loans slash a personal loan
so as my parents that loaned me the
money for the rest of my grad school
um but I would say it was a pretty
serious loan when your mom writes out an
amortization schedule and makes you sign
it so hello that is next she delivered
that with a Hallmark card yeah Merry
Christmas here's some interest
amortization schedule from Mom yikes mom
whips out that word you're in dangerous
well she's an accountant and I have a
dad as an engineer so okay you're used
to that yeah yeah wow okay so was this
did you pay it off before the
Thanksgiving dinner got awkward that one
was it yeah I paid it off over the
summer oh that's good for you okay so
what else
twenty thousand on a car because then
you get a real job you have to get a new
car right that's right yeah it's a rite
of passage yeah do something stupid okay
and what kind of car was this uh it's a
RAV4 and you still got it great oh love
it we'll go me and Ken will go check it
out sure yeah
oh okay so tell us how you got on this
Ramsey Journey what got you started on
the Ramsay way so um I had been slowly
paying off my
um loans over 2021 and then I was at a
gas station and my credit card was all
mangled and I was like trying to shove
it in the thing you know to pay gas and
it made me go inside and I had to read
off the number to the guy at the gas
station I was like well that was
annoying and so I was like maybe I've
been swiping this thing a few too many
times and so then I went home and I
looked at my credit card statement and I
had always paid it off you know with
what was in my checking account and the
first time the balance was higher than
what was in my checking account and I
was like this is not gonna work I gotta
figure something out and I was just like
so embarrassed at that I had spent 600
on food the month before wow so that you
had that pain in the stomach feeling
going yeah oh my gosh I can't even
afford to pay this off off yeah
um so then I had heard of Dave Ramsey in
the past and I started to listen to the
podcast and then went to an FPU class
and got serious so then over the next
seven months I paid off 45 000. whoa so
yeah 45 was gone in seven months yeah
the last seven months how did you do
that
um I just worked every day almost except
for maybe two days a month
um I stopped eating out I used the every
dollar app
um I just really cut down on my expenses
and put every extra dollar you were
living on nothing yeah what kind of
meals were you eating because you said
you were spending a lot on food what I
just couldn't quit going out quit buying
drinks out and as much going out with
friends
um and just ate more at home did they
understand or were they like oh that's
weird but okay
um yeah I had some friends that were
like I mean I guess if that's what you
want to do but I mean I'm not gonna do
it but you survived it socially I did I
still have friends yes because a lot of
people are scared to do this plan
because they go I gotta live my life
Jordan yeah you want me to do man yeah
but how far did you uh stretch your
groceries
um I shop at Aldi a lot so I'm a big
Aldi Shopper and George is so happy
right there yeah warmed my heart
recorder in the cart yeah you went viral
for telling people that that's right
what was your controversy statement I
said the average meal at home is four
bucks average meal eating out is 13
bucks it's 225 more 3.25 times more and
I got so much hate skewered yeah
yeah but you're telling me that it's
true it's way cheaper to go shop at Aldi
than it because people say well oh yeah
my time is worth something George and
your time is clearly worth a lot more
than theirs is you make good money yeah
how do you justify just cooking at home
and wasting all of your time doing
dishes and cooking
um I like cooking so it wasn't too bad
um but I just made time for him and
realized that on the other end then I
can eat out whenever I want when I don't
know
what was your first meal like after you
paid off the debt you're like I'm gonna
live a little
you were still shopping at Aldi yeah
still shop at Aldi yeah I love it in the
RAV4 there's this little compartment
that like coin and I have one quarter in
there for my Aldi cart yes
get a shopping cart out you have to put
a quarter into the cart it's very
old-timey and that releases the cart for
you to shop with boy that that takes
nickel and diming to another level but
it forces you to go put back the cart to
get your quarterback out all you get the
quarter back once you put the cart back
all these Audi people like is it obvious
to everybody that I've never darkened
the door of an Audi before yeah well
it's Aldi
Audi is a Vehicle Manufacturer I know
what Audi is oh it's Aldi yeah okay all
right I think it's German I'm gonna take
some notes over here this is not a
sponsored uh call for I feel like this
whole thing took on like a Food Network
uh theme well Ken this is for people her
age it is one of the biggest hardest
part was it not hanging out with friends
was it what was the most difficult part
of this journey because you went after
it
um I think the hardest part was just not
taking as many vacations not doing as
much trying to make things cheaper and
then honestly just working a lot I mean
I worked three weekends a month so I had
like two days off a month so I didn't
really have time to do anything anyways
what was the okay so I we hear these
stories a lot and I love the fact that
you are younger uh what would you say to
young people who who are in the
situation you were in and they're faced
with work in themselves to where they're
bone tired but for a very clear goal
what did you mentally say to yourself
what when you when you felt tired maybe
you didn't want to go in you kept
working crazy hours what was the message
for yourself
um I think I had never planned to live
in Georgia and I always wanted to move
after that so it was the fact that if I
wanted to move and do something else
like I didn't want debt strapped on my
back so it was just kind of the end goal
of I'd rather just do this short term
work a bunch get it over with and then I
can do what I want do what you have to
do so you can do what you want to do I
love that so many people have goals they
have dreams and they can't pursue those
because money is an obstacle in their
life and I love your story because
you're saying hey if you would just be
willing to sacrifice for 19 months for
you you can have all of that on the
other side I never could have made this
move to Colorado and had my stuff in a
storage pod and taken a few weeks off
work if I was living paycheck to
paycheck I never could have made it
happen so I felt like once I did that
kind of like the world is your oyster
now I can do what I want and go where I
want and yeah so what do you tell people
the key to getting out of debt is
um I think the budget was big for me
like realizing where I was spending my
money and where I could really cut back
and then also just having that end goal
in mind
that's awesome well we've got the live
and give box for you to give to someone
else to use it for yourself it includes
The Total Money Makeover baby steps
Millionaires and one year Financial
Peace University have you been through
the newest edition uh no I did it right
before it changed oh well maybe time to
go through it and take a friend along
with the journey who went hey what do
you that stuff you did when you weren't
eating out and now you don't have any
debt can you show me how to do that
that's what's going to start happening
and we're so proud of you and real quick
who do you got with you I got some
support with you um this is my mom hey
mom love it she's the one that made the
schedule amortization school I know I
trust me I that's why I wanted to get
some attention on her all right we don't
hear that one accountants love attention
I know that oh that is true oh my
goodness well we are so so proud of you
you are us just showing people what it
looks like to do this plan and do it
with a smile and still enjoy your life
and now you've got the rest of it ahead
of you to truly live your dreams achieve
your goals without debt on your
shoulders
all right the moment we've all been
waiting for Ken it's Amanda from Macon
Georgia 60 000 paid off in 19 months
making 74 up to a hundred thousand with
overtime and crushing it and shopping at
Aldi count it down let's hear a debt
free Scream one two three I'm debt free
[Applause]
to hear the word amortization schedule
again or Audi apparently no I needed my
apologies to the Fine grocery chain I'll
I'll get that right for the future oh
but I love it willing to do whatever it
takes yes for Freedom solving for
Freedom that's what I want for all of
you listening in 2023 Amanda showed you
now it's up to you are you gonna do this
stuff or not you get to make that choice
this is the Ramsay show
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
this is the Ramsey show all right listen
up for the business owners out there do
you feel like you never have time to
work on your business because you're too
busy working in it or you are not alone
we talked to thousands of business
owners every year one of their biggest
problems is not having enough time so if
you feel that way let this be the year
you learn to trust your team and
delegate tasks so you can really do the
important work of growing your business
you can find out exactly how to do that
by checking out delegation the latest
quick read from Dave Ramsey that drops
today that's right you'll learn the why
the when and how to delegate and you'll
learn the two reasons why owners don't
delegate and how you can overcome them I
mean you're learning how to delegate
from Dave Ramsey himself the same guy
who started his small business with two
employees and now leads over 1100 team
members here at Ramsey Solutions he
knows a thing or two about delegation
and remember your business will only
grow and Thrive to the extent that you
commit to delegating so pick up your
copy of the delegation quick read today
at ramseysolutions.com store and while
you're waiting for that book to arrive
you can check out the latest episode of
the entree leadership podcast which I
host and uh Dave Ramsey and James Clear
are our guests on this episode and they
talk about the importance of habits and
delegation you don't want to miss this
one you can find the entree leadership
podcast for free wherever you stream
your podcasts open phones this hour
triple eight eight two five five two two
five we're taking your calls about money
life work purpose you name it and
Mitchell is on the line in Montgomery
Alabama Mitchell welcome to the show
hey thanks guys I appreciate you all and
Ramsey Solutions I've taught FPU at my
church and uh the situation I'm in now
which I have lost my job
um I had worked at a school a private
school where uh had a great head of
school that I worked for and he left and
shortly after that the board chair came
in and told me that my physician would
be eliminated so I'm on a about a eight
week leave and then uh working on
finding something else
so my question is a couple fold but
mainly how do I represent this time
um to Future employers future schools
I'm also looking at educational
consulting firms and I've had my own
consulting firm before so I'm thinking
about just starting that up but how do I
represent I've got some interviews
coming up and I am still employed by the
school I coach there still I've decided
to stay on and do that and finish up the
season but uh just curious how you in
your wisdom would represent that to
Future employers
uh it's a great question and let's start
with you don't need to have any sense of
shame I mean people get laid off I mean
we saw uh some very large companies with
a pattern of uh you know sizable layoffs
as we went into the fourth quarter third
fourth quarter of last year it's largely
because people are trying to anticipate
a recession so layoffs in uncertain
Economic Times it's kind of the norm and
uh it's also very normal when you have
transition at the top
so you've been laid off
in a certainly uncertain economic time
and you were also laid off as a result
of leadership transition
so there's nothing to be ashamed of I'm
speaking to your heart and your head
first
but it sounds like to me you're still
employed there so as you're representing
this you you're not even bringing up the
fact that you've been laid off I mean
you're still employed there it's just
you stayed on as a coach it may be less
money maybe less time but it's not like
you have to go in and go well I just got
laid off but I decided to stay as a
coach I mean the bottom line is is you
are very experienced as an educator true
or false
true 20 24 years in school uh and you
were also you were not laid off because
of any type of behavior or uh lack of
production true or false
that's true I was not yeah it's
restructuring and mainly Financial for
the school so that's the narrative if
you even have to bring it up but the
bottom line is you're still employed
correct
yes so we'll be till the middle of
February so as you're searching and
they're saying okay why are you joining
us the the answer is simple
um the school the recent Headmaster who
I work for he's transitioned out uh the
board is looking to make several
organizational changes and uh it's
pretty apparent to me that I'm not going
to be in the long term there due to
financial reasons and I want to stay in
the game I mean that's the that's the
conversation that's the narrative
there's no shame there's no spin it's
just the facts
great and there's nothing listen they
appreciate that because you've got
something to offer so you're always
focusing on what you can do but when
they're asking why you want to join us
you're not trashing anybody you're not
you're taking the high road which you
have on this call and so you control the
narrative hey bottom line is new my old
leader who I loved is gone Financial
issues at the school and it's best for
me to move on and I want to stay active
and and I want to be proactive not wait
for the for the shoe to fall if you will
I'm going to move forward so that's all
I would do
that's that's great let me ask you this
I started my own educational consulting
firm
um a few years back to give my wife
flexibility to follow her career and I'm
planning to just open that back up in
the near term
not knowing what the future holds would
it that be another positive direction
that I decided to open that up and leave
the school did you make did you make the
same kind of money when you were doing
that as a consultancy that you're making
that you were making in a full-time
educating role
ironically I made almost double oh gee
whiz yeah yeah I I would absolutely
start it back up do you have reason to
believe that you're going to be able to
get back to that kind of Revenue pretty
quickly
uh you know it's all all based on
network relationships and uh pandemic
help too I help some schools change
their model in the pandemic and that's
what it was and I tell you what I would
do based on how you answered that I
don't think your confidence level is is
there that it's going to do that so what
I would do is I would keep applying keep
interviewing and let's land a
traditional role in education and then
let's also do this other thing on the
side and let's see where it goes and if
it starts to spike back up again then I
think I would go go that route depending
on what you want to do do you want to
work for yourself or you don't work for
an institution as just I'm on this team
I think you get to decide that but as of
right now I would not just Bank on the
consultancy firing back up that quickly
I would hedge my bets by getting another
education job relaunching the
consultancy and let's see what happens
that sounds great thank you for what you
do and I'm able to rest easy because we
have the emergency fund with debt free
except for the house and oh that's
amazing that is awesome proud of you
Mitchell keep your head up I know it
stinks and I would also say Mitchell
don't touch that emergency fund
losing your job
is under the level of an emotional
emergency but it does not have to be
George no I'm going to try to keep
income initial emergency let me explain
that because there are layoffs on the
horizon I mean I'm just telling you I
don't know where I don't know when I
can't see into a crystal ball like that
but anytime you have talk of a recession
uh certainly for larger companies this
affects public company employees
certainly more than others okay but if
the recession really does begin to
strain small businesses then you're
going to see an impact there but
you should have a plan at all times
the emergency fund is for those
emergencies but you should also have a
plan just like when we get on a plane to
fly somewhere George in the fine flight
attendants get up and hey if there is a
water landing you know here's what you
do and George never pays attention so I
have to pay attention for him thank you
and uh you know it's like do I have a
plan
if I if I had to have a water landing if
I was laid off
what would be my first three moves okay
or you make up the number but I think
people don't do that enough and so the
point is is like all right so do I have
some relationships that I know I could
call and I know that I'm pretty
confident I can get a 15 20 an hour job
or I could get this or I've got
something I could sell like start to
plan like you would for a storm
and when the storm hits you've got a
plan you've got an evacuation route
you've got
water you know pair you know
non-perishable food you know that's the
idea financially so that uh I mean
professionally and occupationally so
that if a layoff hits you it's not a
true emergency it just sucks and it's
one reason to do this Ramsay plan
because like Mitchell's situation he
goes it's unfortunate it's frustrating
but I'm not freaking out either though
because I've got a pile of money in the
bank I don't owe people money and it
changes how you make those decisions so
good wisdom there Ken wishing the best
for you Mitchell thanks so much for
calling in that puts this hour of the
Ramsey Show in the books my thanks to my
co-host Ken Coleman all the folks in the
booth we got Austin Ben James Zack and
Nathan and you America thanks so much
for listening we'll be back real soon
Dave here you can find all of our shows
with the Ramsay Network app on your
smartphone it's the only place to listen
to the entire back catalog of episodes
download the Ramsay Network app in your
favorite app store today
[Music]
[Music]
live from the headquarters of Ramsey
Solutions broadcasting from the PODS
moving and storage Studio it's the
Ramsay show where America hangs out to
have a conversation about your life and
your money I'm George Campbell host of
the entree leadership podcast fine print
and co-host of smart money happy hour
joined by the host of the Ken Coleman
show you guessed Ken Coleman himself
next to me taking your calls on money on
career on life whatever's on your mind
America maybe you get some goals that
you have set out for 2023 some
resolutions we want to help you get
there and give you hope in every area of
life it's a free call at triple eight
eight two five five two two five and
kicks us off in Tulsa Oklahoma and
welcome to the Ramsay show
hi there happy New Year how are you all
you as well we're doing great how can we
help today
so the first one is how
is huddle when I really don't have a
desire to move up into management
although I do value recognition and
achievement and then my my second
question is whether or not it's a wise
move to join the Air Force Reserves or
the Air National Guard within the next
year or two knowing that the past two
years have been full of a lot of change
and a lot of trauma for me so it's kind
of a two-fold question for you all hey
wow now we get some real depth here so
let's let's go for number one first does
that sound okay sure that's great so the
heart of your question is what I heard
what you said Okay I want to grow or I
want to be recognized I love the way you
put it you want recognition uh but you
don't want to be promoted into a
leadership position am I understanding
that that is correct I love growing
accounts and I love earning more money
and being wise with that money but I
don't necessarily want to move into a
management role
um whereas my organization I'm at right
now is run by former Consultants who are
really demonstrating that up or out kind
of method of dealing with attrition and
I'm also getting some mixed messages
from a direct manager who very kindly
has said I'm the best person on the team
and she needs me so she can't promote me
so I'm getting some mixed messages and
what I really want to do is you know be
the best individual contributor I can be
and be wise with my money well it sounds
like tell me what I want to do so it
sounds like to me the message that
matters is your director is your direct
leader and I would tell that leader hey
um this is a match made in heaven
because I don't want to lead I in fact I
get a little bit of of anxiety when I
hear that these consultants and our
leaders are kind of going up or out or
whatever I feel like I've gotten that
message but I gotta tell you I'm as
happy as I can be in the role that I'm
in
crushing it and I want to get well I
want to make more money and I want to
make the organization more money so I
make more money so I can manage my money
well I want to stay in this type of role
I'm happy to be your top performer
please protect me because I don't want
to be promoted into a leadership role
but this is what's weird about George uh
our Western Hemisphere
the way we we treat promotions it's like
well you gotta move up the ladder
instead of going what do you want to do
more of do you want to make more money
and do a little bit more of this you
know why does it always have to be I'm
going to pull you out of the seat where
you're crushing it and put you in a seat
or you may not want to be you may not
want to leave people but you might be
the best salesperson so they go well she
needs to be over the sales team and lead
them so on your misery yeah so I think
the answer to number one is
reaffirm what your leader is telling you
and going I'm as happy as can be protect
me and I want to stay here all I want to
do is is keep performing better get paid
more and spend that money wisely that's
that's what I think okay you got that I
like that I like it love it now the the
second one because I want George to jump
in on this retirement thing but I've got
to ask George
um when you say you've been through a
lot of change and Trauma uh whatever
you're comfortable sharing I'm just
curious what that has been and how long
that's been going on
chair and there's actually some
a lot to deal with and heal with so in
the last two and a half years excuse me
um I I got sober I moved across the
country thank you thank you I had a
major surgery and a traumatic divorce I
lost over 110 pounds I changed companies
and I was finally diagnosed and treated
for ADHD so lots of great things in
there but also lots of things that make
me pause and say okay I want to make
sure that I'm making the right decision
because this would be like a 20 it
didn't have to be a 20-year commitment
but I'm looking at a 20-year commitment
in the reserves or the guard because
it's important to me I want to serve my
country and do something so beyond
myself all right so that leads to what I
was really going to dive into and let
George talk about it as a retirement
option sounds like to me you want to
serve your country more than you're just
trying to juice your retirement benefits
but that is kind of a benefit pardon the
uh the metaphor here is that what I'm
hearing I would say that's correct
because I couldn't even tell you the
dollar amount that those that retirement
would be it's much more about serving my
country
um also family lineage my grandfather
and my father both served and this is
really important to me would it stress
you out your current family relationship
life I know you're just recently
divorced I'm so sorry about that but
would this extra time
in serving our country do you have
margin for that towards not a negative
would it affect other parts of your life
your job anything like that
No in fact uh at my job most of us have
served in some capacity I'm also single
and happily Child free
um so I don't view it I know I I don't
think it would I mean it would here's
the truth it would take away from my
yoga on the weekends that's what it
would take away from we can live with
that exactly
Namaste there you go mistake well then I
would do it and I would do it for the
only reason that you want to serve your
country and anything else is just an
auxiliary benefit that's a nice to have
but I would never do it for the
retirement benefits and it sounds like
based on what you told me your heart is
in the right place with this and I would
pursue it if I were you if that if
that's what's uh where your heart's
saying to go then the retirement benefit
is just part of the package do you have
retirement as part of your current job
I do I do um however I've worked at
startups for the last about eight years
or so
um however have had very steady
employment at startups but we all know
how startups go so that's always kind of
in the back of my head like I've got a
great retirement consistently putting 15
a year towards that but I do feel a
little bit behind I didn't really get my
first like grown-up job until the last
about eight years or so so a little bit
of it yeah there is part of me that
wants to make sure I'm playing catch up
but that's not the main motivator behind
this are you debt free
I am I'm debt-free I'm on baby step 3B
right now that's awesome so soon you're
going to be a homeowner that's going to
help you build wealth what's your income
yes sir uh 125 I make 125 000 a year oh
I lost you were gonna retire with plenty
of dignity and plenty of time to enjoy
as much yoga as you can handle
we'll probably be teaching the class by
then
hard to talk with you
in advance for serving this great
country what a cool call lot to to
manage there can but she's very well
spoken and I if I was a hiring I'd hire
Anne yeah that's great and I think by
the way she said learned ADHD and she's
but but there was a woman there this is
highly focused and she's live and just
rattling it off and I think the serving
is a great way to heal huge this is the
Ramsay show
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
thank you
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
back to the Ramsey Show Happy New Year
to all of you listening out there and
while most of you are saying good
riddance to last year because it was
hard enough just to keep gassing your
card and food in your fridge uh money's
still tight and you're wondering right
now is 2023 going to be any different
well guys you do not have to live
through another year of stress and worry
regardless of what is happening in the
economy and that's why I want you to
watch Building Wealth in 2023 our free
live stream event on January 12th
because we want to show you that you can
still make progress on your goals you
can build wealth you can have peace with
money even in this crazy inflationary
time regardless of what's happening in
the white house you can do this stuff so
during this event you're going to hear
from myself Dave Ramsey Rachel Cruz Dr
John deloney and Ken Coleman we're going
to talk about how to set goals and
create margin so that you can build
wealth this year we're gonna have some
fun and you're gonna leave fired up for
2023 and even if the economy he still
feels out of control you don't have to
you can control the controllable so
register for this free live stream go to
ramsaysolutions.com wealth that's
ramsesolutions.com wealth uh George I
have a non-money question but I think
the audience uh would like to weigh in
on this all right all right how long can
you say happy new year
at what point in other words at what
date on the calendar in January James
you can weigh in on this James are are a
Fearless producer what is the date by
which the window you stop saying Happy
New Year because everybody's saying
Happy New Year and I want to keep it
going on the calls today is there a date
I've got a hot taken I think the further
the relationship the longer window you
have and I think 30 days is the longest
window yeah so friends and family you
get two days I go January 15th I think
after the on the 16th it's time to where
it's dropping we're all we know we're
all happy well by then I'm just learning
to write 2023 instead of 2022. what do
you say James
to me like a couple days like oh okay
I'll say it to people at work today
because it's the first day back seen
them but starting tomorrow if you see
James in the hallway
yeah
like you said how much you know the
person if you don't know very well and
you're you're scraping the body tell her
at the bank and it's January 17th they
might say Happy New Year I have the same
question about that first email to
somebody in a professional context of
the new year like at what point do you
not say hope you had a wonderful holiday
season your years off to Good Start like
is it February one yeah holiday season
gets a little tricky too Ken there's a
lot of holidays how long are we
stretching the season for the older I
get folks the crankier I get on this
issue I just think if you want to see
happy New Year fight don't expect me to
say it you're turning this into a
Seinfeld bit what's the deal with happy
New Year what are we doing well I just
think we all know that we want you to
have a happy New Year you know I don't I
don't ever see somebody and go crappy
New Year who says that can I tell you
something this is embarrassing I'm going
to admit it to you in all of America
when I was young I was a young kid my
grandma said Happy New Year and I said
back no happy New Year and she cried and
I will never forget that moment I've
never felt worse in my life I don't know
it was probably 10 11. wow maybe 13 I
got no clue I was a very emo I was such
a punk little emo kid it is and I still
feel bad to this day so Grandma if
you're watching have you written her a
letter I apologize profusely okay
through her tears Ken it was ah never do
that to your grandma's let alone anyone
you know what you're doing you're owning
your past and changing your future wow
yeah there it is
all right before they take us off the
air let's get to a call uh it's a free
one triple eight eight two five five two
two five hey that's important stuff
you call the show to talk about your
life and at the unnecessary happy New
Years need to stop at some point the
only thing more important is Ashley's
question and she's waiting with baited
breath in Huntsville Alabama I'll let it
go Ashley I'm sorry and happy New Year
to you okay happy new year thanks for
having me how can we help today
yes so I had a question for you all
today
um my husband and I just finished baby
step two we started watching you guys
last year
um ended up paying off our car loan
early and some credit card debt and so
we're on baby step three I'm currently
saving about 10 for retirement while we
fund our emergency funds
um so my question is last year we ended
up moving to a new primary residence
um we have about 400 000 left on our 427
000 mortgage and we left our residents
that we used to live in put it up for
rent um and we had about 150 000 left on
that mortgage
um so I guess my question is do we need
to sell because we considered moving
back to our old residence just to get
rid of our big mortgage
um do we sell one of them to move to the
other or do we sell the rental and then
my other question is my husband and I
don't agree on whether or not we need to
pay off our loans because we have a low
interest rate on both the primary and
the rental house
um and so he kind of wants to keep it up
full 30 years and I'd like to try to pay
it off earlier
that's like saying hey do we want to
keep getting punched in the face because
we're not getting punched that hard in
the face so my take is that I want to
get rid of all debt that's stealing from
my income and once you do that you're
going to have total control of every
dollar coming into your household so
there's a few things here I just want to
point out right now you're doing
Ashley's plan which is fine but you're
asking for Our advice and that's going
to be the Ramsay baby steps which is we
are saving up that emergency fund and
we're not investing a diamond to
retirement until that's fully funded
so that's one you said you're investing
ten percent so I would bring that 10
down to zero temporarily while we get
the emergency fund in place
and on the housing situation could you
guys move back into that rental what
made you move in the first place
um we were looking to get into real
estate into
try to get some extra cash flow from a
rental
um found a house we locked those a
little bit better so we're thinking
about starting a family here soon
um so just wanted some bigger space
what's your household income
um right now with both of our jobs is a
hundred and eighty thousand dollars and
then the rental is bringing in about
twenty five thousand okay and how much
more space for this uh little one
um we moved it was about 1200 square
feet in our current home is now about
2500 square feet okay so it sounds like
you need the the extra space in the 2500
square foot one
I mean yes would it be tough to go back
it has been good to be bigger okay it
would be very tough to go back yes
because based on numbers it sounds like
you guys can healthily afford the
mortgage payment making 180 a year but I
would sell the old one I would never
encourage anyone to have two mortgages
at once the way if you went back in time
I would say hey let's pay off your
primary residence and then if you want
to save up and pay cash for an
investment property you can do that
but right now there's a lot of risk
hanging around you're trying to do 17
things at once and you're not making the
progress you should be making with your
income
okay
and I mean how much time have you go
have you all spent as a couple just
talking through if you did what George
told you to do like what that windfall
and how it would fast forward everything
how it would bring more peace if you
guys sat down and really dreamed and
kind of talked about what if
her husband's biggest thing is that we
have such a good interest rate on both
homes that he just thinks it's like
wasting money to pay off the home in a
sense well I think that mindset is going
to continue to hold you guys back when
you look at well it's a low interest
rate so let's just keep it hanging
around our necks for fun so I get that I
get that that's his response George but
but I mean are you sitting there going
how much money would you make on that
house if you sold it
what's it worth
we could probably make at least 270 to
300 on it
270 to 300 000 that's what you would
make
well that would be the sale price of the
home and then we have 150k levels so you
could get 150 150. okay but see so
that's the number
so if I'm sitting down with your hubs
and let's say I'm playing older brother
with them I'm going okay dude you want
to hang on to this house and you're
making 25
000 a year on it but that doesn't
include I'm guessing that's your gross
that doesn't include expenses and upkeep
is that correct correct yeah so you're
not making twenty five thousand all it
takes is one roof to be replacing an
HVAC so let's let's say let's round down
let's just say you guys are making 18 on
it okay net
versus the 150 after Realtors fees or
whatever let's just take those numbers
I'm looking at that going what would
that do for us
this dude's getting all excited about
18.
versus 150 and no debt my goal is to owe
no one nothing including the mortgage
payments his goal is to hang on to as
much low interest Mortgage Debt as
possible because that's somehow a path
to Building Wealth and so we
fundamentally disagree in that regard uh
you can try to change his mind you can
go through Financial Peace University
with him read The Total Money Makeover
that's our plan is complete Freedom not
let's try to be a real estate gurus with
a million dollars of debt hanging around
her neck yeah cast some Vision about
where that 150 would allow you to fast
forward your life he needs to see that
this is the Ramsay show
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
this is the Ramsay show I'm George
Campbell Ramsay personality joined by my
colleague Ken Coleman and we are taking
your calls at triple eight eight two
five five two two five now many of you
have a goal to pay off some debt this
year and so we want to inspire you right
now on the show with a debt free
screaming to do that we've got Dylan and
Crystal joining us on the debt free
stage how you guys doing doing well yeah
doing great where you guys from we are
from Denver Colorado I love it how much
debt did you pay off we paid off 67
178 wow and how long did that take about
28 months awesome what was your range of
income uh we started out at 77 000 and
ended uh around 107 000. awesome what do
you guys do for a living uh so I am a
non-profit uh program manager and I
worked in fraud prevention at a bank
um but currently unemployed okay uh
Dylan do me a favor here I'm producing
the show all of a sudden pull that mic
up closer yeah we want to be able to
hear you my bad there we go hey guys I
got this okay it's got it I got it I
love it so sixty seven thousand dollars
what kind of debt was that so it was a
lot of student loans uh we also had a
car loan and we had some credit card
debt I think that was most of it and uh
some money that I stole whoa whoa hello
hold on so you were in fraud prevention
at the bank did this happen while you
were in fraudberg no no no no okay he's
exaggerating yeah a little bit so the
long story short my mom had some money
set aside for me for college and she uh
trusted me with it she you know wrote me
a check and I said yeah I'll use it just
for school and then I was unemployed for
a little bit and I started dipping into
it a little too much so I finally
confessed and said I need to pay this
back is she here with you she is she's
right here this is not the first time
she's hearing this I assume no okay good
she seemed unfazed by this information
so I was hoping so yeah so okay okay so
that's what you mean by you stole it
yeah yeah he's not going to jail no no
that's good paid it all back that's
great but it has a big turning point for
us so yeah so what brought you to that
I've had at moment where you guys said
we're doing whatever it takes to get rid
of this debt yeah so we were both raised
the Dave way we actually both did FPU as
kids
um in our respective families and
Dylan's mom is actually a coach uh
Ramsay coach so awesome um it's in it's
in the family but we both as young
adults just made choices that
sounded good to us but weren't weren't
wise and so
um his his thing being one of them and
um when we were about to get engaged
that was really when we were having
those big conversations about you know
what do we want our life to look like
when we're married and so we started
planning out before we got married how
we were going to move forward
financially whoa so how long you guys
been married we got married uh March of
2020 so almost three years we got
married right as the pandemic was
happening so we were one of those Living
Room weddings
wow yeah and so soon after you got
married you were like we're doing this
plan yep we got to work yep it worked
out with the pandemic tour there was a
lot of online food ordering and so we
did a bunch of doordash and at driving
as dasher's not not buying yes thank you
for making sure people understood
absolutely yep just did a lot of side
gigs I took a serving job at a
restaurant a little bit later on he was
working on finishing school as well so
yeah we just hit the ground running wow
yeah and sounds like you guys were
pretty busy we were yeah yeah how'd you
keep up that communication and the
encouragement who walked alongside of
you what was that like yeah I mean we
had so much support from our family and
our friends which really helped when we
had to make those tough calls you know
every every week when people want to
hang out if yeah we can we can do some
stuff
um but we can't do we can't eat out all
the time
um but yeah we just we had conversations
all the time about here's what we're
running after especially when we were
tired we were like we need to go have a
dreaming conversation so we would go and
dream about the kind of house that we
want or the kind of travel we want to do
and that really helped keep us motivated
yep the life we want to live yep and
Dylan I gotta ask your mom's a financial
coach was she a part of this was she
kind of like breathing down your neck or
was it like hey Mom we got this what was
that situation like oh man she was
amazing she knew she just presented
herself as a resource but said hey I'm
you it's a choice that you have to make
so I'll let you guys do your thing but
if you have have any questions let me
know and we definitely called on her a
few times for you know do we do this or
that kind of wow so parents if you're
listening that is how you do it with
healthy boundaries very gently not
forcefully that's incredible wow and I'm
sure she's proud because you guys went
through financial pieces kids and it
didn't quite stick the first time what
do you attribute that to just kind of
your youth of just like well this stuff
doesn't matter I'm not an adult yet
I was definitely one of those people
that was like I'll just have the the
credit card and I'll always paid off and
I I did I never got into trouble with
that but I definitely the wake-up call
for me was after my first year of my big
girl job I did my taxes and saw how much
I made and I was like I don't have that
much in my bank account where did that
go yeah oh my goodness yeah I know you
can speak for yourself uh yeah I just
decided my parents didn't know what they
were talking about with credit cards so
I got some and uh just they you know
they talk about the free spender I'm
like nine out of 10 on that test I woke
up one day with like twenty six thousand
dollars in credit card debt and I was
like I couldn't breathe I was making
less than that per year
uh yeah I was having panic attacks and
eventually I had to call my parents and
say hey I've hid this from you
um and I need help wow yep how did that
feel when you finally let that out and
share with that share that with your mom
and dad oh man it was it's kind of like
you know when you have to throw up you
have all this pain but once it's out
it's like oh that was painful but oh I
can breathe now that's a good analogy
you guys are different people than you
were three years ago five years ago
you've totally transformed has this
affected your marriage too
oh absolutely I think just having a
common goal
um having to make hard choices together
were both Spenders and so we're often
having to help each other stay on track
um yeah and from the day that we got
married uh we've always shared a bank
account I'm not we're not on anything
that the other person's not on for that
reason that's great so how does it feel
to be completely debt free oh it feels
awesome
we can actually celebrity and chillness
to you I'm like yeah we're just vibing
right now yep we can actually work
towards something now we got ourselves
out of the hole now we can now we can go
up so so what would you tell people that
other couple that's out there they have
a pile of debt maybe they went through
financial peace and it didn't stick what
is the key to debt Freedom yeah uh so
there's two things there's like
practical steps and then I guess
emotional steps for practicality what we
did is uh we got one month ahead on our
expenses so our you know our paychecks
all always go to our savings account and
then at the beginning of the month we
make a budget based on how much is in
that account and transfer the money to
our checking for all the bills and
things
um so that's a practical thing that we
do yeah and then on the emotional side
like I said just keeping that dream
Central and so constantly reminding
ourselves why we're doing this because
it it makes a lot easier to say no to
the right now things if you're saying
yes to them the long time things what
are you willing to sacrifice
now for a better future
a great question to leave us with those
you guys are incredible we are so proud
of you we're going to make sure you
don't leave uh today without the live
and give box to give to someone else to
use it for yourselves it includes two of
uh Dave's best-selling books Total Money
Makeover and baby steps millionaires
that's the next chapter in your story
and of course one year membership to
Financial Peace University maybe uh you
can show someone else who didn't stick
the first time you say hey go through
this with us we're going to lead a class
and this one's on us we want to show you
the way so we'll make sure you guys get
that thank you we're so proud of you all
right let's get to it the moment we have
all been waiting for we've got Dylan and
Crystal from Denver Colorado
67 178 dollars paid off in 28 months
making 77 up to a hundred and seven
thousand dollars doordashing and all
count it down let's hear a debt free
scream three two one we're dead free
foreign
[Applause]
yeah yeah it's fun it's fun to see you
know it never gets old to watch people
recount the journey and then the
countdown is kind of the final moment
where they break through you know the
the ribbon and they just did it and
that's what it's all about here's a
young couple with their entire life in
front of them favorite statement from
the scream is when crystal said hey
now we can work towards something now
they're dreaming if you live like no one
else later you can live like no one else
that's going from surviving to thriving
that's what this plan is all about way
to go guys we are so proud of you and
it's available to you America if you
want it it's there it's on the other
side of sacrifice and intensity and
slashing expenses and making more money
but you do that for a short period of
time the rest of your life is going to
be incredible you can do this this is
the Ramsay show
[Music]
thank you
[Music]
you're listening to the Ramsey Show I'm
George Campbell joined this hour by Ken
Coleman well about this time of year
folks we get flooded with calls because
everyone is looking for a fresh start
with their money especially after a
tough couple of years so if that's you
you can't wish for things to change and
expect it to happen you've got to do
some different things with your money
you've got to have a plan and we can
teach you that plan in Financial Peace
University this is the course that will
help you rethink how you manage your
money and you're going to learn step by
step how to pay off debt and build
wealth and nearly 10 million people have
gone through financial peace and
University they followed this plan and
changed their lives I am a recipient of
the that if this plan worked for me and
it can work for you don't try to
reinvent it don't try to do your plan it
just doesn't work we've dialed this
thing in when you intentionally follow
this plan with Focus intensity this year
can and will be different you're going
to have more peace in your finances and
your life it's the best thing you can do
this year for your money start Financial
Peace University right now at
ramseysolutions.com
FPU that's ramseysolutions.com FPU
all right it is time for our question of
the day Randy emailed in from the great
state of Arkansas he writes I am trying
to decide if I should keep my job as
Assistant Branch Manager at a bank
making 31 dollars per hour or take a new
job
at a Superior Courthouse making twenty
four dollars per hour as a legal process
clerk at the bank I have to pay around
300 for health that have been a health
benefits per bi-weekly paycheck and the
courthouse benefits are paid 100 by the
court both jobs offer opportunity to
grow I'm 35 years old married with two
kids what do you think I should do well
Randy I think you should do
the work or do the job that puts you on
the ladder to grow where you really want
to go and this entire question seems
like it's built on benefits George the
cost of benefits so you're the numbers
guy George all right so he's making
Thirty One dollars per hour
right now at the bank but he has to pay
300 for health benefits per bi-weekly
paycheck so I'm guessing now that's 600
a month is my math still correct Jordan
that sounds right all right so 600 a
month
um and any 7200 a year 7 200 a year the
question is is that before or after
taxes my guess is that's before taxes I
would hope that's that's the benefit I
don't know but either way let's assume
that let's assume that but either way
you're looking at seventy two hundred
dollars so if we just take the 31 per
hour and you you put that you know
course of the year if he's just doing 40
hours a week and you play all that out
do the math on that
um then you look at it from a an Apples
to Apples but I I think he's still
better off yeah he's making a big
situation he's making uh almost 15 grand
more at the bank okay so if you subtract
and again I don't think it's minus this
he's he's losing by moving to the
courthouse even though they're paying
for that so you've just got to look at
the numbers because in one what what
happens is when you don't look at the
big picture George then then there's a
motion instead of facts the emotions go
oh I'm paying 600 a month for health
care and at the courthouse I'd pay zero
well you're making a whole lot yeah I
never want to make any decisions just
based on a benefit alone never ever ever
that's my professional advice don't take
a job take the numbers solely on
benefits would you rather be an
assistant branch manager at a bank or
would you rather be a legal process
clerk that's right and which one are you
better at and you have more passion for
he puts in there that both jobs have an
opportunity for growth well again let's
look at them side by side where do each
where does each job take me okay if I
grow here on the bank side where does
that take me if I grow here on the the
courthouse side or whatever the city or
municipality or the county where does it
take me and which direction do I want to
go that's the decision process and my
guess just a hunch that in banking there
is a higher trajectory for salary
there's no question with the state or
government state or a municipal
government unless he's going to go go to
law school and become a lawyer yeah I
think it's going to be tough to get to a
much higher level of income so he's 35
with two kids I'm sticking with the bank
job for now and maybe that's not even
the career path maybe there's something
totally different out there for you you
gotta explore that don't just settle
because you go well it's it's a good
safe job I provide my family go after
something that really gives you the
juice as Ken would say oh I love hearing
you say that George thank you great
question thanks so much for emailing in
it's an open uh open phones right now
triple eight eight two five five two two
five let's talk about your life your
money your work your purpose Ian is up
next in Annapolis Maryland Ian welcome
to the Ramsay show
thank you very much sir thank you guys
for having me absolutely how can we help
today
so my wife and I have been huge
followers of Dave Ramsey for about the
past 10 years uh we're active or I'm
active duty Navy and I had them for
about 14 years now
and we move every three years now my
question for you guys is right now we
have finished baby step five we have no
debt we have our daughters colleges
completely paid for we're trying to
figure out is it better to buy a house
or keep living in military housing and
saving five grand a month
uh until we retire from the military
how many years would that be
uh so I had I'm at 14 now I'd be about
six or seven at the earliest
and you're saving five grand a month
uh X not including our 20 toward tsp or
our 401K wow you just have five grand in
cash you can put in a savings account
every month yes sir so we're putting it
right now we're putting about three
grand into our non-retirement account
and we're putting about 22 000 to 2500
in our money market account
the non-retirement is that being
invested you're saying in a brokerage
account yes sir okay yes sir s p 500. so
just we're putting three grand to a just
S P 500 and we're putting about 2 000 to
2500 every month into our money market
essentially just a savings account
yes sir okay so you've got an index fund
growing over there you've got the
savings account I think there's there's
a lot of wisdom there and you're saying
hey five to seven years from now this
money could turn into 300 500 Grand
yes sir right paying cash for a house I
love that plan and what's what's the
other side of the coin here
uh so we move every three years
obviously we we bought a house at our
last command absolutely loved it uh we
did really well with selling I just
didn't put that money into our index and
now or you know we have about a year and
a half left until we move again
and we're just trying to figure out
everyone's telling us obviously buying
buying has done really well for us in
the past
uh but right now we're happy in military
housing we don't pay bills we don't pay
utilities
uh we're just trying to figure out are
we making a mistake uh living in
Military Highway I don't think you're
making a mistake no you're you're making
the wise decision because five years
from now you're paying cash for a house
while the rest of the goons who are
making fun of you are paying off their
30-year mortgages
and so yeah I don't know who these goons
are that would be making fun of you I
mean this is brilliant this is well sir
yes sir and today's a lot of military
people from what I've met they buy
houses everywhere they go and they rent
them out so everyone around us is
telling us we're making a mistake being
in military housing and we should be
buying and they think it's a life hack
because they haven't gotten burned by
playing this game and uh yeah you simply
don't need to play the game regardless
of what profit they say they're making
because all it takes is one emergency
scenario where they've got to pay the
HVAC or the roof or the renter stops
paying or there's another pandemic and
it's illegal to evict and your tenant
doesn't pay so this is this is a
dangerous situation uh when you've got a
mortgage attached to it and so I would
keep going the route you're going even
if you bought and you once you move a
year and a half from now you want to buy
in the next place and you hold on to
that for three years you would be
totally fine I don't think there's any a
lack of wisdom in that either Ian I got
to ask you this very quickly did we say
anything that you didn't have that you
hadn't already thought of before you
called the show absolutely not sir
everything you guys said just reaffirmed
it right so here's my point you needed
you needed a shot of confidence
yeah and I'm telling you you got it you
are a wise young man you have to drown
out
all these other people you got to decide
what life you want to live
and live it that's exactly what I need
like you guys just you reaffirmed it
yesterday we listened to you the entire
day and we just we figured it'd be best
to hear from you guys directly so glad
you called and thank you for your
service you're a great American wow what
a sharp guy that gave me a lot of
encouragement and it also reminded uh me
Ken like you mentioned drown out all the
noise all the negativity everyone's
saying you're doing it wrong if you are
living your life with the goal of
complete debt Freedom where your income
your greatest wealth building tool stays
with you that is a great plan and good
times and bad
so I'm sticking with that plan I'm
taking that to the bank that puts this
hour of the Ramsey Show in the books my
thanks to my co-host Ken Coleman all the
folks in the booth keeping the show
afloat and you America thank you so much
for listening in share the show if you
enjoyed it with a friend someone who
needs to hear this message and we'll be
back real soon hey folks Ken Coleman
here did you know the Ramsay show is one
of the most popular podcasts in the
world it's your daily dose of advice on
life and money check out all of our
shows from the Ramsay Network wherever
you listen to podcasts
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
live from the headquarters of Ramsey
Solutions broadcasting from the PODS
moving and storage Studio it's the
Ramsey show where America hangs out to
have a conversation about your life and
your money I'm George Campbell Join This
Hour by my friend Ken Coleman
bestselling author and host of the Ken
Coleman show and we're here for you
America to help you kick off the New
Year's strong help you achieve your
goals whether it's professionally
financially relationally you name it we
are here for you the number to call is
triple eight eight two five five two two
five Johnny is kicking us off in Denver
Colorado Johnny welcome to the show
hi guys thank you so much for having me
absolutely what's going on with you
well uh to keep it simple I have about
forty thousand dollars in credit card
debt that I'm looking to erase as soon
as possible
um but it's really difficult because I
only make around forty five thousand
dollars after tax and I owe so much
credit card debt and all my credit cards
are over the limit that the interest
alone is almost the exact amount of any
minimum payments I'm able to make on a
monthly basis so just as of right now I
just don't know how I'm ever going to
even make a dent in this because any
payments I do make the interest all but
absorbs it and I make like no progress
what is the range of the interest rates
on these cards
um there are 25 to 29 oh my goodness I'm
so sorry
what are you doing for work
uh I am a appraiser just like a
valuation analyst for commercial real
estate
can you work overtime in that role
is a salaried position so it's a
full-time gig already I work like maybe
40 to 50 hours a week but um it's
salaried so uh 25 of My overall earnings
are going towards like benefits
Insurance
um 401K savings Roth IRA accounts
um
Etc what other debt do you have other
than the 40 000 other than the 40 000 in
credit card debt that's that's really
just it so no car loans no student loans
um I have thirteen thousand dollars in
student loans but I'm really just hoping
that the vitamin registration would just
kind of wipe that away for me you are
going to be hoping to the Grave my
friend yeah hey I want to go ahead and
give you some breaking news all right
Uncle Joe and no president any party is
going to forgive student loans it's big
business for them they're not going to
do it it's an empty political promise
I'm just here to tell you I want to bash
that so that we can move on to getting
out of this debt you got it yeah all
right so any other debt you want to tell
us about we got 53 total right now okay
uh no that that's it just the the
student loan that I was hoping would
just disappear on its own but uh now
that you're saying not okay and it's 53
total now uh are you a new listener to
the show yes I just found your guys's
YouTube channel about a week ago no
welcome welcome aboard sir welcome to uh
this weird bunch of crazy so here's
here's what I'm gonna do I'm going to
walk you through uh the baby steps
you're in baby step one right now trying
to get a thousand dollars saved in the
bank do you have a thousand dollars yes
okay great how much left over after the
thousand dollars do you have you have
more than that uh after I take away a
thousand I'd be left with a thousand
okay so you've got a thousand left over
how much are you investing right now
um no more Investments I pulled out all
of my investments to pay off some of my
credit card debt and uh like you pulled
from your retirement
no no I don't really have a retirement
account aside from my 401k and Roth
accounts okay um so you didn't touch
those
no I didn't touch those okay so where
you said you pulled it where did it go
from I pulled it from like my stock
accounts that I'd started when I was in
high school okay a couple thousand but
then when the credit card debt became
too much I just pretty much pulled it
all out to make payments towards the
credit cards um but then the interest
kind of just like
went way overboard so what are the
minimum payments right now across your
credit cards uh so the minimum payments
across my credit cards I have three
um big ones it's 300 300 500 pretty much
around 1200 uh minimum every month okay
and you're able to make those payments
but the balance keeps growing
yeah I'm able to make those yes so to
clarify I'm able to make the minimum
payments on a monthly basis because I
pulled in around 3 900 monthly
but the interest is so high or again
like around 25 to 29 that the minimum
payment on one card is 300 and then the
interest is
303. hmm have you looked into
refinancing any of that debt to a lower
interest
I had thought about looking into it but
I'm kind of discouraged because one of
the options was like a credit transfer
card that might be able to absorb all of
the credit card debt that I have into
like a zero interest card but Research
indicates that I probably need like a
minimum 670 credit score to even qualify
for one and due to the damage over the
last three months because of the fact
that all of these cards are over the
limit anyways I don't have enough of a
high enough credit score okay consider
getting a transfer a credit transfer
card how much time do you have George is
going to keep walking through this but I
just got to ask how much time do you
have or could you make to work extra
doing another job
well I work full-time during the
weekdays I could definitely work on the
weekends if and evenings maybe a few
evenings
uh well it's a nine to six gig um so
pretty much uh if I if I don't sleep
yeah you can do it you can uh at six
o'clock you go uh you go eat yourself a
ham sandwich in the car that you and
that you made and do three hours of uber
hours of work man you have got to get
some income in to pay off these cards
and the good news is you can do that
okay okay
this this is a mountain in front of you
but you're gonna start clawing away at
this thing as you create more margin and
so what you're going to do is get on a
written plan a budget I'm going to gift
you one year of every dollar premium to
help you with this you're gonna list out
your income minus all of your expenses
that should equal zero every dollar has
an assignment
once you do that you're gonna look at
your bank statement and go okay what are
every single one of my expenses and then
you're gonna be brutal in cutting every
single thing that doesn't just help you
survive right now and so we're not
eating out we're cutting our
subscriptions we're cutting all the
luxuries we are covering our four walls
which is food utilities shelter
Transportation that's pretty much it
and you're in whatever your insurance
premiums are everything else is kind of
a want beyond just putting basic food in
the table right
right and so if you do that I want to
know how much of a raise you're going to
give yourself of that 3 900 you're
taking home the goal is to say Hey how
do we get 2 000 of that being thrown at
the credit cards how do we get 2500 of
that thrown at the credit cards and if
you need to go make more income to get
it to 4 500 take home then let's go do
that for a season to get rid of this
because we meet people all the time who
make your income who have your level of
debt and they can do this stuff and you
can too the issue you're running into is
the interest rates making it feel
insurmountable but as soon as you start
clawing away at that you get the
balances lower we're going to be able to
cover this and communicate proactively
with these companies and say here's what
I can pay I can't get away from this
right now and some of them may go to
collections but your goal is to try to
clean this up as fast as possible
I'm gonna also gift you Financial Peace
University watch all nine lessons start
doing that every dollar budget and
you're gonna feel a sense of Peace a
sense of hope a sense of confidence
about your future you can do this man
call us back when you're debt free and
share your story and hang on the line
Austin's gonna pick up and get you those
gifts from us
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
foreign
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
Campbell Join This Hour by Ken Coleman
and if you don't know about Ken Coleman
go check out the Ken Coleman show on the
Ramsey Network George wherever you
listen a podcast on YouTube he's
everywhere let me tell folks what it is
since you said they don't know what it
is yeah it's about work the name isn't
that description so Ramsey Solutions is
about money it's about relationships and
work and I'm the work guy and uh we're
about more than just work and a job the
idea is is do you know what your full
potential is and then what does it take
to meet that full potential so it really
is if you're growing personally I got
good news for you you're growing
professionally and so we're trying to
help you really figure out that unique
role where you're making great money and
you're making a great contribution to
the world so that's what I focus on and
we take those kind of questions here on
the show so thanks for sharing that the
Ken Coleman show uh is where you can
join us for a conversation over there
and all the stuff well uh producer James
sent us this article that has to do with
work and I wanted your hot take on this
Ken here's the headline
here's the headline should I take a
lunch break at work one in four gen Z
employees worry leaving their desks to
eat is a bad look to the higher-ups
here's why that's nonsense so it goes on
to explain probably I'm hopefully close
to our take let me answer the question
yes you should take a lunch break
um if you are in a place
where you taking a lunch break is
actually frowned upon I don't mean like
in your head and this data's saying that
a lot of gen Z workers are worried that
it looks bad well there's a difference
between I'm worried I'm manifesting this
thought that's not true and it actually
being true so if George you were working
in a place where your leader is frowning
upon it making passive aggressive
comments about you taking a lunch hour
you shouldn't be there much longer find
you another place uh and here's why
the data Bears out that you're not
actually more productive you may think
you're getting more done but it's going
to end up being a negative for you by
not getting up from your desk and a lot
of these kids I look to the art a lot of
these young people are eating at their
desk they're called desktop diners desks
top diners it's a fun little necklace we
got a name for everything first it was
quiet quitting now we got desktop diners
um
I I think it's good for your mental
health it's good for your uh physical
health uh to get up change locations you
know there's all kinds of data about uh
walking for 10 to 15 minutes before you
have a big meeting
I've talked about that on the Ken
Coleman show you know it's a it's a
creative release
uh it allows you to kind of get some
perspective and uh so anyway the lunch
break is the same idea I you know I got
I have several friends here in the
building that they go work out during
lunch uh Damon Goud my Fearless brand
leader works out during lunch and it
shows it shows
um and you know in multiple ways so you
know I do think that there's something
to that and I'm calling myself out on
this because sometimes I go without
lunch
that has a cool name too Ken it's called
fasting now I'm intermittent fasting
that's what I tell it's real trendy what
it really is is that uh I have poor
planning and uh you know I don't have
time uh but I need to make time but now
for me I keep my energy up during that
time but for someone every day to be
sitting there feeling like I can't leave
my desk or else someone's gonna fire me
or they're gonna think poorly of me I'm
telling you something young people you
have you've got to get some facts to
support that and if you don't have any
facts you need to get over that uh and
just be responsible be responsible well
and that the report that this study
talks about found that stopping to eat
and taking mental breaks can prevent
burnout especially in the context of the
extra stressful times workers have faced
over the past few years and so if you
think you're being more productive
you're actually being less productive
and you're on your way to burnout if you
can't take that break that's right your
your mind needs a a break you know your
body needs the break it's get up you
know uh by the way if if I'm a young
professional
if I'm going to eat out every day and
some of you need to not be eaten out you
need to pack your lunch and go to a
local park but you know what I'm trying
to do I'm making phone calls to people I
want to connect with I'm eating lunch
with people I want to connect with I'm
using that time to grow professionally
but I'm away from my desk absolutely and
it's actually discouraged here at Ramsey
if we see a team member eating at their
desk we're going hey what's going on
here you go we have got a whole
cafeteria where we can connect with team
members and occasionally you'll have a
lunch meeting or something like that by
the way no one else wants to smell your
tuna fish sandwich for the rest
can we can we just let's be real
practical for a moment especially in the
microwave you got to avoid microwave
fish in 2020 if you want to win
professionally don't bring fish to the
office cafeteria not the advice we
thought we'd hear on the show but it's
the it's the advice we got sometimes it
just presents itself and you have to
it's perfect I love it well take your
breaks folks for safety's sake there we
go all right let's get to the phones
triple eight eight two five five two two
five is the number to call Renee is
joined joining us up next in Seattle
Renee welcome to the show
how can we help today
so I work part-time I've been I've been
at my company for about four years now
and I'm wondering should I keep
contributing to my employer 401k or
should I start contributing to my raw oh
do you have a Roth 401k option at work
or is it just a tradition
it's uh I have this my job offers a
traditional but I do have a Roth with
nothing in it that I have with Fidelity
you have a Roth IRA with Fidelity and
then you have a traditional 401K with
your employer
yes okay awesome and are you debt free
no sadly what kind of debt do you have
uh the biggest burden would have to be
our credit card
um how much credit card debt do you have
23 23k any other debt
um car loan house okay so let's just
focus on the student loans uh the the
credit cards and the car loan if we
focus on those two what is all that dead
add up to
so use the credit card and the car loans
I probably adds up to
I'm almost done paying off one card be
paid off next year within six months so
we're talking 50 Grand in debt total
I would say 50. okay let's get some hard
numbers on that and let's be about the
business of paying that debt off before
we continue investing and here's why how
much are you investing right now as a
percentage
three percent three what if I told you
we can get you to 15 that's 5x you're
you're investing right correct
right and so you can do that once we get
rid of these payments because add up all
these payments in your life and go hey
what if I could have invested that money
instead pre-tax in my traditional 401k
now we're talking now you can retire
with dignity so that's the baby steps
that we teach is baby step two paying
off all Consumer Debt using the debt
snowball smallest to largest then we're
saving up a fully funded emergency fund
of three to six months of expenses to
create a financial Foundation because
now we don't owe anyone anything except
for the house and you've got a pile of
money in the bank for emergencies which
means you don't have to ever turn to the
credit cards as a crutch again you feel
that
yes that would be nice because then we
have the margin to invest 15 of our
household income into retirement so now
let's talk about that once you're there
which I think you'll get there in no
time what's your household income
um about 97k okay so you absolutely can
pay all of this debt off with Focus
intensity pausing all investing and
finding that margin cutting expenses
down you can do this in under two years
right
I believe I can and I'm actually looking
for a remote job to kind of help with
the Dead
okay well increasing income is only
going to help and then when it comes to
the investing strategy this is how we
see it match beats Roth beats
traditional so do you have an employer
match
yeah I do actually and that's what I've
been contributing to my employer match
is two percent great so we're going to
invest once you're there you're debt
free with a fully funded emergency fund
we're gonna invest two percent into that
401k to get the match that's 100 return
because it's free money right
okay then we're going to move to all of
our Roth options so you mentioned the
Roth IRA so you could fully fund the
Roth IRA and then if you still have
money left over with that 15 rule then
we can go back to the traditional 401k
and invest the rest there
okay the money I already have in the
401ks that I roll it over to the law no
just leave it in there I'll only roll it
over if you uh leave that employer for
any reason then you can do a direct
rollover to a traditional IRA so it
doesn't trigger any tax penalties or
burdens there so you're doing great
let's just do things with intensity and
with focus in order and you're going to
be back to investing 5x in no time we
are rooting for you Renee please call us
back if we can help in any other way
more of your calls coming up triple
eight eight two five five two two five
this is the Ramsay show
[Music]
thank you
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
this is the Ramsay show I'm George camel
co-host of this show of course but also
smart money happy hour which you can
check out on the Ramsay Network Join
This Hour by my good friend Ken Coleman
host of the Ken Coleman show open phones
at triple eight eight two five five two
two five we're taking your calls about
money career life work purpose and
everything in between Jason joins us up
next in Houston Texas Jason welcome to
the show
hey how's it going great how are you how
can we help
yeah I was just hoping I could get some
career advice today you came to the
right place my friend
all right thank you so um kind of just a
little bit of background
um I graduated with my MBA um end of
August last year and kind of just to pay
my way through school
um I worked at a it's like a Telehealth
consulting firm kind of working in their
call center Division and it's kind of
like an inside sales representative
position
um you know making out on calls all day
and it's a very metrics driven position
and fortunately I've been able to do
pretty well at it and you know was able
to get a pretty nice bonus every month
and that's really helped me you know
graduate debt freeze now the company is
saturated I did have one interview for
you know an account manager position and
unfortunately I didn't get
um the role and there's not a lot of
other job openings there and at the same
time I'm quite burnt out in my current
role and you know kind of over quality I
feel like my potentials being limited so
I guess my question is should I just
jump ship and you know devote myself
pull time to the job search or should I
just continue keeping working this job
um and kind of trying I guess I don't
know try to lay off on the burn out and
keep pushing through it
well it's a bit of both and I don't want
you jumping [ __ ] but I do want you
looking uh for another better
opportunity and you really know what
you're looking for uh I believe or I'll
tell you this by what you just said I
know that you know what you're not
looking for
and so that really should arm you with
some confidence but I want you spending
every waking hour when you're not
working because I don't want you
stealing from your current employer but
you're treating this with super high
priority because I don't want you to
burn out and I think you can hang on
long enough because you've got a very
clear Mission and your mission is I've
got to replace my current job the only
way I would tell you to jump ship
without a job is if you had the
financial ability to do so and I don't
think that's your case
um well I mean I have saved up you know
quite a bit of money where
um I would say about I think by the time
like if I do plan on quitting when I'm
thinking I'll have at least maybe 15K
saved up do you have debt
no I don't have any debt right now is
the 15 what is your emergency fund
um is that your emergency fund
no I mean see I'm kind of in a position
where I'm kind of living at home until
my expenses are pretty low
um and you're saying you'd have 15K to
your name
yes it's not enough yeah it's not enough
what if what if it takes you 60 days to
get the job you want
right
I don't want you dipping into that
because you don't have to unless the
again I don't think you qualify for the
well I'm financially set and I can
take two three months without any income
I don't think you're there not by my
standard and I don't think by your
standard if you really look at it and
I'm glad that you have the safety of
having
um very little expenses but why burn
through any of that fifteen thousand
when you don't have to yeah the only uh
thing now that I would say is if you're
in a truly like your doctor's going I'm
advising against you going in there
because it is that damaging to your
health
right and I don't think that's the case
either but I think with with you going
all right I'm not happy here I know why
I'm not happy here and now I'm free to
go find something I know what I'm
looking for and I'll I'll help you I'll
give you my get clear assessment I'll
give you the books on paycheck to
purpose both of those are my gift today
all right to help you with further
Clarity so that you can confidently move
forward
clarity
is the key to confidence
okay yeah and so I want you clear on
what move you're going to make next in
other words George I'm working right now
on a smaller book on this and the
outline is and this is for you Jason
it's why to quit you've laid out the why
then we've got to figure out where to
quit
then we say once we know the where we
figure out okay what's the win and
that's pretty much determined right by
the opportunity we understand that and
then finally how to quit doing it the
right way and not Burning Bridges that's
your process right now you've got the
why we need to figure out the where and
then the when and the how will take care
of itself
how old are you Jason
uh well I just turned 30. okay my goal
for you also would be to get your own
place your own apartment maybe with a
roommate but move away from Mom and Dad
and give yourself that dignity where it
is on you and you feel like an adult and
so I would be aggressively looking for
that next job get that lined up save as
much money as possible because life's
going to get expensive when you're on
your own so that would be my next goal
just stack up a giant pile of cash and
get that job that you actually want
versus just doing this one because the
money's good and it's safe
sure yeah now that makes sense
we don't want you touching that money
Jason don't touch the 15 000 unless it's
a true emergency I want you finding
something else to step into and I'm
going to give you the tools to help you
get further Clarity yeah hang on the
line Austin will pick up we'll make sure
to get that over to you thanks so much
for the call all right Jacqueline joins
us in Fort Worth up next Jacqueline
welcome to the show
thank you I got a chance to speak to you
and Ken back in March the 28th of last
year oh fun
Ray Charles that's James Brown
I love that well thank you so much for
calling in how can we help today
okay now I have I'm debt free except for
my house at that time I had beds and I
told y'all better then so I had a buyer
from my house nice
about 10 days before
we get rid of the clothes they
disqualified too uh have the load any
longer so the financing fell through
yeah they're financing sales
so I am here waiting I reduced my house
uh
uh about twenty thousand trying to keep
up with the market
and um
I got my stuff in boxes
and I'm not gonna be uh moving out until
I found some paper on the downline but
the thing is my question is
um with the Market's going the way it is
I guess you would have to continue to
be competitive with the market to keep
going up or down or whatever
sure
what's your question
the question is in order to sell the
house when you get competition around
you
is it
I'm not going to vote for solo it's
necessary to kind of go with the market
with the sale of the house and the value
of the house well you can have a you can
have a threshold and say hey I'm not
going below this if that's the case I'm
staying here and I'll just keep living
here until the Market's back up and that
could be a long time we just don't know
uh we know we don't have a crystal ball
here are you working with a really good
real estate agent
uh I think I have a good real estate
agent he's the same one that um tell me
the purchase of the house that I'm in
now okay you can always get a second
opinion somebody like within a week yeah
well you can get in touch with one of
our endorsed local provider real estate
agents they're Ramsay trusted and uh
these people sell a lot of homes they
are the pros and there are some in the
Fort Worth area that would be happy to
give you a second opinion on this uh you
don't have to work with them if you
don't want to but I think we need a
second opinion here because I if the
house isn't moving and you've already
dropped it by Twenty Thousand something
else is wrong if off the market now
we're down to twenty thousand went
online it wasn't on the marketing line
we took it off the market to kind of
um well hard to sell a house when it's
off the market isn't it
it's off the market now but we're going
to put it back on the market this month
okay I might wait I might get in touch
with a real estate endorsed local
provider ramseysolutions.com and see
what they say because I think you've
you've got a marketing issue you may
have a pricing issue we just don't know
without looking at the details but you
need someone who is a high octane real
estate agent to help you move this house
at the price you want to move it for and
I absolutely think they can help you do
it so thank you so much for the call
wishing the best for you with this home
sale so you don't have to have those
boxes laying around too much longer this
is the Ramsay show
[Applause]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
welcome back to the Ramsey Show I'm
George camel joined by Ken Coleman this
hour
our scripture of the day comes from
Proverbs 11 3. the Integrity of the
upright guides them but the Unfaithful
are destroyed by their duplicity
Henry Ford once said quality means doing
it right when no one is looking
love that Ken that reminds me of our
Ramsey core value excellence in the
ordinary you went a little deeper it
reminded me of how you do your hair
what's that
nobody's looking when you're and you are
really precise about it thank you uh we
we had the I had the privilege of being
on a uh retreat with you oh that's right
and here we are actually no I didn't see
it I heard it you heard the blow dryer
before we head out on the boat this guy
doing a 10 minute get his hair right
routine before we go on the boat and to
me I thought that's what it made me
think of no one was watching you but
your boy it is it is well coiffed the
higher the hair the closer to God is
that what the real thing Dolly Parton
said that I don't know that's how I live
my life you know I interviewed her once
really yeah I'll tell you she seemed
very pleasant yeah very nice lady
awesome well let's get to what you're
you're here for America and that is the
calls Triple eight eight two five five
two two five Ava joins us from
Springfield Illinois Ava welcome to the
show
hi um I have a question I have about
half a thousand dollars in savings and
cash and I'm aware how to like get a job
and I've been some side jobs like
babysitting and gift wrapping and I make
about over a hundred or two hundred
dollars each time but I want to know how
can I set up good financial habits
before experiencing debt and how to know
whenever I should spend money on things
that I want and hanging out with friends
or just on savings how old are you Ava
almost 14. oh wow that's fantastic
that's incredible wow you know that you
are so much smarter than most 24 year
olds I met 34 year olds
thank you where did you learn this stuff
like where did this mindset come from in
this work ethic
um I watched the Dave Ramsey Show with
my dad and they my parents kind of teach
me how to use money wisely that's
incredible where they're raising you
well we appreciate you being a listener
so let's get to your question so you
said you have how much in the bank right
now
um I have about over a hundred in the
bank and then over
250 in cash so 250 cash 100 in the bank
what is your next financial goal
um probably saving for a car wow okay so
a few years from now let's you're you're
almost 14 you're driving by what 16
Illinois yeah okay so in two years how
much money do you think you could save
up if you kept this up maybe you know
you you go get uh I don't know the age
limits and requirements in Illinois but
could you go get a job somewhere at 14
years old
uh yes most likely on top of your gigs
doing babysitting and gift wrapping and
all that because gift wrapping is pretty
seasonal I imagine
yeah yeah but the babysitting is where
the bank is I've got a 14 year old
daughter named Josie Ava so you guys are
you two are close in age and uh she's
making pretty nice money what are you
getting for uh babysitting yeah what's
the hourly rate
um depending on the family one family
excuse me 20 an hour and
families pay me 10 or sometimes I just
get 20 or 40. wow I'm going to tell you
something I'm gonna try to find me about
five more twenty dollar an hour families
that's the first thing all right you
enjoy it I'm serious do you enjoy it
yeah I oh yeah I love hanging out with
the kids and it's flexible you can do it
kind of on your own schedule right now
because are you in school as well
uh yes I am in school so you're limited
to kind of uh some evenings weekends I'm
sure on school nights it's a little
harder mostly weekends uh yeah
I love it well I would set a goal have
you talked to your parents about uh if
they are going to be contributing to
this car
um so my brother my oldest
oldest he
got for it so my parents could afford to
help me but we usually have to pay on it
on our own so that we can learn how to
save money you say pay on it do you mean
with payments
uh no with cash okay oh yeah I want to
make a Ramsey girl oh come on all right
so maybe pitch this say hey Dave Ramsey
here's what he did with his kids it's
called the 401 Dave plan where I'm Gonna
Save an amount and you as Mom and Dad
will match whatever I save up to a
certain limit so you might say hey if I
save up up to three thousand dollars
will you guys match me dollar for dollar
up to another three thousand that would
give me six thousand dollars you think
they would do that okay
um I could ask I don't know
that's your homework right there is have
that conversation with Mom and Dad right
now if they say no we're not giving you
a penny then it's on you and so then
maybe it may take a little longer it may
take more work to get to that six
thousand instead of three but that's a
great goal to have on top of also
enjoying your life as a 13 year old girl
and hanging out with friends and going
to the mall I don't know what the kids
do these days what do you do for fun Ava
yeah I hang out with my friends our
mom's still cool can you just tell me
this is this is deteriorating Ava I'm
sorry I'm gonna rescue him he doesn't
I'm trying to help I'm helping America
I'm the father of teens all right no
hanging out at the mall it's not cool
it's me and James hang out at the mall
all the time well look at you two so you
need I say anymore gosh uh Ava here's
the deal I think this I think George is
giving you great advice on laying it out
with Mom and Dad whatever amount they
gave to your brother is probably what
they're going to consistently do for you
so take that amount and then what I want
you to do which is really powerful for
for uh young people and adults is when
we're saving for something big is to
visualize that and I think it'd be fun
for you spend some time with Mom or Dad
on the used car market you know online
and just get an idea some cars that you
think are are cool or cute or whatever a
13 year old girl would call it but a car
that you like and you begin to see
um how much that car costs your mom and
dad will say well that's got too high of
a mileage or whatever but begin to just
get familiar with it now in two or three
years the used car market may change a
little bit but by and large it's going
to give you an idea because I want you
to be able to know okay I think I want 8
000 or I think ten thousand or I'm gonna
be okay with five I think have that
visual
in a very specific Financial number is
going to be huge for you and then you
can go get a job maybe at your grocery
store or a fast food place or whatever
Plus babysitting and then you start to
go all right how long is it going to
take me to save up this amount of money
and before you know it you're going to
be there oh yeah and Ava it already
sounds like you never want to touch debt
is that correct
yeah that is the number one factor to
your financial success is if you never
touch that you never open a credit card
maybe once you turn 16 you get the car
you open up a debit a card at your local
bank or credit union and use that to
start paying for your car expenses for
gas for food and all that as you get you
know maybe a job while you're in high
school and that's going to set you on a
path for Success if you have that
mentality that debt is off the table and
when it comes to college or further
education we're not going to go into
debt we're going to whatever we can save
up in cash that's how we're going to
explore education and that's how I'm
going to explore my next car and the
next thing you are going to be so far
ahead of most of America it's going to
be mind-blowing
okay thank you we are so proud of you
thanks so much for the call Ken that
just gave me a put a little pep in my
step to talk to Ava I gotta say yeah
well now you should know when you talk
to 13 year olds don't ask them if they
hang out at the mall I don't um
what's cool yeah well that's what it is
that's probably misguided as well those
days are over first I know you and I
being cool we can't go to them what are
we doing what are we doing here we gotta
you got a car to get on it's over man I
never exact pack it up exactly I mean
nobody cool wears a cardigan but I'm not
cool well a seven-year-old dressed by
his mom or a 48 year old man
those are the two options Ken knows I
love a good cardigan yeah you have you
ever worn a cardigan I love Cardigans
yeah you actually look uh quite dashing
in the car yeah it means a lot yeah
there you go well a Happy New Year to
you Ken it's been a fun show yep fun
times I got a phone call by the way is
why we do what we do and YouTube because
she's watching the show on YouTube and
her parents good on her parents for
setting some expectations that are
really going to help her later on in
life this that's really you know what
got me Ava has a higher net worth than
most of America so at 13 years old that
should inspire you to Greatness America
to make some changes this year to
increase your net worth by getting rid
of the debt which gets your net worth to
zero and then start investing for the
future have a pile of money in the bank
that is financial peace and good times
and bad regardless of what happens in
the world this next year so we are
rooting for you we're here for you and
we're gonna be back real soon my thanks
to my co-host Ken Coleman all the folks
in the booth Austin Ben James Zack
Nathan and new America until next time
spend wisely save intentionally and give
generously
the Dave rant one the latest Ramsay show
videos going viral check out
check Everett moments from the Ramsay
show on YouTube go watch And subscribe
to the Ramsay show channel on YouTube
[Music]